the official line for Dwayne Haskins the
former Ohio State quarterback taking
15th overall in Washington is that I'll
play whenever they want me to play I'll
play if they want I'll sit if they want
I'll do whatever they want every once in
a while the true feelings will sneak out
recently NFL's Twitter account said
raise your hand if you're ready to see
Dwayne Hoskins in action and he raised
his hand now that doesn't mean that he's
he's defying his vow to do whatever the
team wants him to do I still believe
that he will do and he will be a good
teammate and he will he will comply with
whatever the coaching staff decide of
course question is when will we see
Dwayne Haskins on the field that's story
line number 29 as we approach the 2019
season and Chris there are different
ways this can go there are three
candidates in Washington and I think
Dwayne Haskins can end up being a very
good quarterback the tension is going to
come from Jay Gruden and his desire to
remain employed because if you want to
remain employed you truly want the guy
that gives you the best chance to win
football games this year and it may not
be Dwayne Haskins because coke McCoy
knows the offense far better Case Keenum
far more accomplished at the NFL level
in large part because Haskins has never
done anything and it could be tempting
for Gruden to go with one of the
veterans especially because it's always
easier to flip from a veteran to the
rookie than it is to go with the rookie
and if the rookies no good what are you
gonna do bench him right and slow his
development or so you know I think that
even though long term it would make
sense to throw Haskins into the fray I
could see why Jay Gruden would decide to
go with one of the other two guys at
least at first to see if they can throw
together enough early wins that maybe
they do have a shot at a playoff berth
because if they don't make it to the
playoffs Gruden's not gonna be there
next year to coach Dwayne Haskins anyway
yeah it's a good conversation and you
brought up a lot of good points first
off that I think the first thing is hey
it's encouraging regardless that Dwayne
Haskins has interjected himself in this
conversation and all you got to do is
kind of look at what Jay Gruden's said
about him you know even at the end of
mini camp and OTAs and like he made some
comments like oh yeah I mean he's
definitely got himself into the
conversation you know you know they've
kind of talked about
that Dwayne Haskins has made some throws
and some plays that have opened up
everybody's eyes to go whoa so he
obviously has talent - you know belong
as a day one starter do all those things
it's just is he seasoned enough you know
is he need to be good enough - Jay
Gruden also one of the last press
conference he talked about just hey I
hope Dwayne Haskins doesn't fall asleep
at the wheel you know over the next
month here you got to continue to work
and he's gonna work about you know the
language of the offense and getting in
and out of the huddle and I'm sure and
Dwayne Haskins will do that but you're
right Mike the safe play for a Jay
Gruden the guy who might be on the hot
seat here at the end of the year is
maybe to go with with the more
experienced guy like a case keenum or
Colt McCoy but this Thank You Kristin in
the back this is the million-dollar
thing right here Mike do you want to
throw out Dwayne Haskins at Philadelphia
Cowboys at home bears at home at Giants
and then the Patriots to start his
career and that to me will all be
predicated on his mental development
through training camp because whoo that
is not an easy start to the season yeah
I agree with that take and I look I'm a
big believer in throwing a guy right
into the fire if you think that a guy is
worthy being drafted with the
first-round pick yeah then he's worthy
being put on the field and if you don't
think he's worthy of being put on the
field then draft somebody else yeah the
window is too limited for these coaches
to show that they can get results - to
justify a multi-year project draft a guy
that you think you can put on the field
and play and I I think that that Haskins
can be effective right away but you're
right you throw him in week 1 he may
take some lumps the team may take some
losses and then and then and then you're
hoping that he shows enough progress at
the end of the year that ownership
decides to allow Dwayne Haskins to
continue to work with Jay Gruden because
you're not gonna be able to say hey we
made it to the playoffs you're gonna
have to come up with some other fallback
plan to convince the owner to not make a
change and I think that's gonna be a
little too tenuous for Gruden because
all in all he hasn't done enough to
maybe earn another year if he doesn't
get to the postseason and he seems to be
very aware of that reality which tells
me he
maybe going to lean toward a veteran at
least to get the year started and then
rely on that that sense of when the
right time will be to flip it the
problem is the buy is week 10 yes right
it did they'd be better served Chris
with an earlier buy this you know they
would but yeah I mean to me you know
what you said there at the end yes I
mean Jay Gruden's very aware he's a real
guy he's a great guy Jay Gruden so he's
he's aware of the situation and its
totality and yes Tamia would make you
know the most sense unless Dwayne
Haskins just blows everybody away
through training camp and they go oh my
gosh he's all over the offense he knows
everything knows every check every
audible if that's the case hey maybe you
do start in week one but if there's any
doubt you go with some of the more
proven commodities and then what does it
take to get to Wayne Haskins in there
you know I mean you know after week five
if they're two and three right you know
that might be enough to where they go
okay we got the Dolphins they're not
very good maybe that's the week at home
in there there's one factor we haven't
mentioned yeah supposedly ownership made
the call on drafting Dwayne Haskins
ownership may ultimately make the call
on window and hairy displeasure what Jay
Gruden wants may not matter
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports